Russian officials are blasting a vote in
Congress for a new package of sanctions
lawmakers in the House overwhelmingly
voted yesterday for the measures they're
in response to Russia's meddling in the
election the sanctions also come after
the country's military moves in Syria
and Ukraine the bill moves to the Senate
now Charlie d'Agata is in Moscow charlie
good morning good morning from Moscow
the Russians are already considering
ways to retaliate as Washington moves
one step closer to imposing new
sanctions here Russian Deputy Foreign
Minister Sergei Ryabkov said the move
defied common sense it would only worsen
relations and warned that the two
countries are now steering into
unchartered territory another lawmaker
said the only course ahead is to come up
with a painful response to Washington's
decision and the director of the
International Affairs Council andrey
korsunov told us Russians aren't exactly
thrilled about being thrown into the
same basket as Iran in North Korea so
basically the signal is that you three
bad guys you will get the same treatment
from the United States Congress and with
all due respect but ruff is not North
Korea now ultimately the only meaningful
response or retaliation will come from
Russian President Vladimir Putin who is
so far remain silent on the developing
situation Gail
all right thank you Charlie d'Agata
reporting from Moscow